et bien bonjour à tous et le retour du
japon pour ma part ça m'a fait beaucoup
de bien c'était très agréable mais je ne
vais pas raconter ma vie vous savez
souvent quand je reviens du japon j'ai
des petits délires la dernière fois
c'était les quatre chapeaux ces trucs
dans lesquels tu mets une pièce tu
tournes et à une figurine au hasard du
coup je m'amusais à choper des petites
figurines de tous les gars de chapeau
noir qu'il y avait des chiba donc j'ai
une petite collection 100 pas sympa mais
vous l'avez déjà vu jouer déjà montré
avant ça je ramenais souvent des objets
ou est de fait qu'on ouvrait avec mac
faye karito et cette fois c'est les
trains voilà enfin pas les trains à
taille réelle les maquettes de trains
oui
bref je m'explique le japon c'est un
pays où c'est des oufs des trains ya
plein de trains différents et il ya
vraiment des passionnés de trains là-bas
et jean rède pilote de trains ces gens
un métier hyper prestigieux et même
bossé dans une gare tout simplement dans
une gare peu importe le poste c'est un
métier qui est vraiment stylé là bas ils
n'ont pas du tout la même vision que
nous d'être un haka la sncf et le retard
vous connaissez probablement le
shinkansen c'est l'équivalent du tgv
mais au japon qui a une gueule vraiment
futuriste qui est super beau mais il ya
des tas d'autres trains c'est ils ont un
réseau ferroviaire qui est très très
très poussée du coût de cette passion et
n'est le modélisme ferroviaire
ah oui le modélisme ferroviaire comme
son nom l'indiqué c'est comme le
modélisme tout court à savoir faire des
maquettes très réaliste à une échelle 1
16e 1 8e 1 je sais pas combien thiem
sauf que là c'est centré sur les trains
donc tu peux acheter des rails des
trains qui tourne qui sont hyper
réaliste hyper cali c'est pas des trains
avec lesquels on joue quand on était
petits enfin bref c'est un truc pour
adultes pour les passionnés de ça et
j'avoue que j'ai été piqué par sa je ne
saurais pas expliquer comment ça m'est
tombé dessus comme ça j'ai découvert ce
truc à la gare de kamakura au japon dans
laquelle il y avait une petite boutique
qui vendait des espèces de trains
miniatures mais je savais pas ce que
c'était au début et je me doutais même
pas qui pouvait être mis sur des rails
et avance et du coup je suis allé un peu
plus tard dans mon séjour à akihabara
dans une boutique spécialisée de sa qui
vend un milliard de trucs de modélisme
ferroviaire et j'en ai pris on va
essayer ça tout à l'heure et j'étais
tellement impatient que j'ai trouvé un
bar où le principe du bar c'est que au
milieu de la table il ya qu une table il
ya une maquette de malades de shibuya
avec plein de trains qui passent et
j'étais comme un ouf
en témoigne cette souris instagram bref
regardé quelques vidéos alors comme
d'hab regarder des vidéos de mecs trop
fort trop stylé trop charismatique et
ensuite on va le faire nous-mêmes mais
ce sera nul à chier à côté de ça mais on
s'est quand même content et fier alors
one on met toi ça c'est shinkansen on a
reconnu les vrais les puristes bon là là
ce que vous voyez c'est une maquette qui
est genre qui est très très énervé c'est
vraiment pas accessible ça y'est ils ont
carrément reproduit des villages avec
des piétons et tous et c'est ouf all
away non mais la mecque c'est un level
ça m'énerve
non mais ça m'énerve alors il ya aussi
des trains français
regardez et ouais ça existe en france
est moins développé que là bas mais il
ya quand même des gens en france qui
font ça peut-être votre voisin même ok
ça c'est le haut à ça c'est fou mais ah
bah tiens guinness world records de
bâtir c'est le record du monde de la
plus grande maquette voilà trop vite
attends attends j'ai rêvé où les [ __ ]
d'avion était automatisé la hâte en quoi
quoi c'est un truc de ouf je suis
halluciné on dirait une vraie vie delà
là on dirait pour le coup on dirait que
c'est vrai que c'est pas une maquette
mille 300 trains y là le gars il à 315
pardon ses arrières veut le mec il a
automatisé des décollages et des
voitures qui roulent en plus des trains
mais j'ai tellement ri dit que j'aurais
jamais dû mettre cette vidéo lama non
franchement c'est la première vidéo que
je joue j'ai envie d'applaudir les gens
dedans quand elle motive c'est beau quoi
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ça
on en sait un nom ça va être adorable
avance space and all his fellow une
flore secret team attend sert la vidéo
émotions ou pas je peux plus moi je peux
pas en faire tout de suite comme ça
c'est pas possible
oh oh non au nom c'est trop mignon au
jeu lors il n'est même pas dans des
conditions de ouf il a fait ça là où il
pouvait dans sa maison et là où ça
dérangeait pas sa femme
[Musique]
or il a fait un vrai truc incroyable
attention façon des cas de la fosse rb
terre c'est qu'il ya du lobel j'ai
l'impression non c'est trop beau et
c'est marrant comme chacun va faire un
paysage un peu différent un type de
trucs un peu différent trop bien trop
émouvant incroyable doublement émouvant
qu'il soit âgé maintenant ce monsieur et
qui continuent à aller dans le sous le
sol de sa cuisine pour refaire son
circuit lala ya le facteur passion plus
monsieur âgé trop mignon là qui me
voient ça m'a tuer bon bah écoutez
maintenant je pense que vous avez bien
compris de quoi je parle et moi j'ai
fait une vraie erreur en vous montrant
ces deux vidéos parce que nous on est
ridicules mais au moins nous on sait la
première étape qui mène ensuite à avoir
sous ta cuisine chez toi un truc comme
lui quand je vous dis que j'attends ce
moment depuis une semaine jour et nuit
c'est vraiment vrai quoi abonnés
[Musique]
talât là je suis excité cela ce pas
messieurs dames c'est la tam qui va
accueillir ma maquette de professionnels
pas du tout je suis nul tout d'abord
commencer par le plus nul deux
adaptateurs parce que du coup c'est les
prises japonaises quoi donc j'ai prise
adaptateur japon bds france qui ça
intéresse notre train là dedans il ya
des rails et le train ni plus ni moins
mais ce n'est pas tout j'ai acheté une
garde j'espère au moins que trois
personnes sont excités comme moi la gare
je vais sortie je les prix monter en
vrai c'est leur hymne qui l'a fait merci
lorraine parce qu'en vrai c'est plein de
petits éléments à mettre dans des trous
et ça laisse à personne le faire en
vidéo elle est là elle est déjà prête et
y aurait une petite surprise après vous
allez voir ça vaut vraiment le coup la
surprise rester jusqu'au bout halak et
la vidéo ça vaut vraiment le coup via un
concours à la fin vous voyez la gare
vous la voyez un petit a vraiment ouais
y'a les sièges qui sont là ici il ya un
escalier d'arriver ici à un distributeur
carrément y en a partout au japon vous
le savez pour ceux qui vont au japon et
si on a une petite lampe voilà comme
comme dans les gares japonaise
finalement pas son autre âge je suis
excité comme un oeuf
l'ag mode d'emploi la ga [ __ ] moi
regardez moi ça c'est les trains mais
qu' aujourd'hui je suis livré à moi-même
on a pas de vidéo tuto mais normalement
ça devrait pas être si compliqué c'est
une sorte de test pour voir si je suis
digne de continuer ses vidéos activités
manuelles donc regarder on va sortir ça
je vais mettre les petits wagon juste
que la regardait ses qualités ils sont
lourds à regarder il ya des petits trous
dessous
a on dirait une vidéo de puristes
deuxième wagon et ensuite on à l'avant
du train cayla qui va s'illuminer
on n'est pas là pour blaguer hockey
l'alimentation avec la fameuse prises
japonaises facile et même que aux états
unis on s'en fout et enfin le petit
boîtier de contrôle
attention et du coup là dedans
logiquement c'est les rails ou là on a
beaucoup pour la loi je m'attendais pas
à ça qu'est mec je déballe sa comme à
noël c'est je lis rien je me dépêche
précédente alors mode d'emploi donc il
ya des grands détournant est un moyen
d'outils que j'ai pas c'est bon pour
vous donc il faut juste en boîte et les
rails ce qui semble assez logique juste
pressé j'ai passé en fait j'ai peur de
casser le truc donc tout d'abord on
emboîte les rails les uns dans les
autres ça ce pas compliqué ok c'est
compliqué on va essayer avec un autre os
s'est passé un truc
en fait il se pète un rail tout est
foutu c'est ça qui me met une pression
hockey le premier rond effet sa
logiquement ça va là ok ça c'est fait ok
plus qu'à faire l'autre côté et on va
pouvoir poser le trac quoi j'ai pris le
truc hein j'ai pris la main il dépasse
de la table il doit achever le matin
diagonale je vais tout mettre au milieu
je vais le mettre en diagonale des nex
des voiles magnifiques ici je vois qu'à
une petite plaque en plastique ça veut
dire que ça doit sûrement partie de la
géorgie ni je sais je suis un génie
c'est un truc de malade comme je suis un
génie non mais attends donc un câble non
pitié faites pas ça les japonais comment
je vois ni de circuit au boîtier qui
commande le circuit c'est lauren comme
tueur à la hache j'ai dit c'est ouais il
est la haye s'était mêlé à l'autre câble
pardon loorent après un petit dégât
collatéral je suis désolé ok donc
comment je relis ça au rail je crois que
c'est là c'est bon c'est elle a alors
l'étape d'après si tu mets ça sur les
rails puis tu mets le train sur ça et le
train va sur les rails suspense et pour
bien emboîter dans les oreilles mec
c'était hyper satisfaisant
ok c'est sur les rails donc maintenant
on va mettre la gare juste ici comme ça
ok là le train est arrêté
c'est incroyable non ok ok tout est bon
mais je crois qu on y est est ce que
tout le monde est prêt c'est en route
il passe sur le câble j'ai fait un
accueil tuque sans faire exprès question
jusque là mais gâche pas le moment
il regarde jamais à fond
[Musique]
je me sens tellement d'émotion à la fois
c'est trop bien
c'est une sensation de ouf je rigole par
l'avant du train et illuminé regard des
[Musique]
illuminés
je fais des plans comme levier d'être
encore là haut je suis un réalisateur
maman mes jeunes âmes dans le magasin
cholet je vous ai dit avec grave des
accessoires et parmi ces accessoires se
trouvaient ceux ci c'est une somme boxe
il ya des hauts parleur portatif que tu
colles sous la station et ensuite tu
peux envoyer des sons qui sont les mêmes
que ceux dans les gares au japon
préserver sa gma telle vidéo plutôt
parce que sinon on en avait pour un
siècle
bon en fait ya un vrai travail de câbles
non quoi mais c'est le grain mais c'est
le drame la médée est fait pour votre
externe drame de l'amour te plaît papa
c'est reparti c'est reparti pourquoi
alors normalement on est enfin bon donc
la paf le train s'arrête
et là c'est les vrais musique que y'a
quand le train est à quai au japon suis
là je sais pas c'est quoi bon est ce que
maintenant je monte le climax de cette
vidéo
après on est bon on aura fini c'est de
la merde
bah écoute et voilà c'est la fin de la
vidéo honnêtement j'ai kiffé mais juste
la sphère salah bon voilà on te casser
mon dernier délire du japon il y en aura
sion occupe une fois que j'ai vu c'était
vraiment cool franchement je suis trop
content d'avoir acheté ça et d'avoir
testé avec vous voilà j'espère qu'il y
en a qui se découvrir une nouvelle
passion après la cpt quoi y'a vraiment
juste des rames mais quand tu commences
à habiller autour avec des petits
piétons des petites voitures de la
faussaire d'une petite montagne et tout
ça commence à vraiment de la gueule
donc voilà j'ai des délires de personnes
âgées mais j'assume je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment cool et d'ailleurs si
on a dansé le passe temps et qui
regardez cette vidéo pas déjà désolé
comme à chaque fois j'ai vraiment fait
un truc pas où mais bon faut bien
commencer quelque part
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer des photos de
vos oeuvres sur les sur twitter ou quoi
j'adore après avoir fait une vidéo
activités manuelles recevoir des trucs
de gens parmi vous qui sont trop forts
dans l'activité manuelle en question en
tout cas c'était très cool at il dit
[Musique]